it's like a circus out there it's a
condom gun fire the condom
these things friggin sting when
oh real quick this video is sponsored by
bombfell uh more on that in a moment
our friend matt invented this thing and
he said hey you guys should try a couple
of these out because they're really fun
you can shoot anything with them you can
even hunt with them what yeah so he sent
us a box dump it all out here and see
what he gave us
there's arrows there's three of [ __ ]
arrows in this yeah
yeah you can i told you you can hunt
with them it looks like a big condom it
feels like a big condom
as well
oh and a tube what the
butt plug
condoms
from what i understand you can put one
of these arrows inside and actually
shoot an arrow so that should probably
be the first thing we try so there's
this thing which is like a it's like a
hairy butthole you could say that
it's made out of a whale baleen
from their faces
there's this
looks like a cow tongue so you can just
put this in your pocket you can even put
your ammo in here and have it ready just
be like walking down the road you're
just a regular guy
walking down the road and then birds
attack yeah then you see a rabbit in
downtown l.a
hey
shotgun dude wrist rocket shotgun oh
that would definitely hurt it hit me did
you get hurt no
because i hit i wore clothes i saw it i
saw these things on
whoa
prices
i was trying to hit the thing dude i'm
sorry it's great that you can hunt with
these but what makes them way more
applicable is whether or not you can
shoot a nerf dart out of them
you shot him
don't don't shoot it don't shoot it
there's a battery in there do not shoot
that
bombfell is an online personal styling
service for men it's all fully
personalized all the clothes have been
hand picked by a dedicated stylist
and what they do is they actually scour
all like the brands and designers from
around the world and like try to choose
specifically what's best for you yeah so
your personal stylist will actually
email you their selections and you have
48 hours to you know choose or cancel or
do what you want you have total control
yeah there are any like hidden fees or
anything like that they're on your side
it's a super straightforward service
they don't make any money unless you
decide to keep something
so what's cool is that you only pay for
the stuff you keep you know there's no
charge just to return stuff send it back
and hey if you decide to delay your
shipment you know a day or week we have
complete flexibility to do so or hey if
you're interested in some sort of gift
option for a significant other you can
sign up on their behalf i think they'd
like that
here's what i don't get why why am i the
person getting these why aren't why
aren't you getting it
because they're for you they're my
hi
so i'm just gonna oh wow these open
really easily look at that
look like a youtuber
finally see i've always been more of
like a utility over fashion kind of
person but who doesn't like to look good
dude i'm a particular fan of these jeans
these are great oh my god what if i what
if i do this but the only one that put
it here is cool oh just just the one
this is cool you sure
okay i'm trusting you carmichael you're
welcome you should do a power pose
there you go
there you go buddy
so if you found this interesting and
want to find out more about this
bombfell service check this out
bombfell.com saminiko if you go to that
url you can actually get 25 off your
first purchase using this service so if
you guys want to get some of those
clothes click the link down in the
description or go to the url b-o-m-b
fell dot com
simon nico i think you can spell that
last one oh yeah
hey buddy
sam seriously don't do that seriously
don't do it
[Music]
highest power nerf gun you can get
holy crap dude
i just got it
got a sling dinger
[Applause]
dude i got a magazine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like i mean yeah you just got to
imagine the entire scene is one giant
grid all the buildings and walls and
people within that that grid should obey
the grid laws
so john and ren how's it going with this
commercial it's going it's it's a lot of
work this video is very very similar to
smallest empire basically that means you
know 3d tracking all these drone shots
populating the scenes with things like
buildings people foliage they gave us a
bunch of like 3d models to use but we
have to retexture all of the models
ourselves which
is cool i like doing that so that's not
a big deal but the biggest challenge is
just like putting them in the right spot
in the scene we have an export that we
deliver to the client and they give us
notes on that and one of the notes that
they're like
we want to see more wallets and it's
like okay we can do that so we're
putting in a lot of walls today so i
mean we're kind of getting to the more
fun stuff check out all my key frames
jeez that's not that's not even all
though
and on top of that we got to get all
these elements of people on green
screens
do you have to do all the roto work i'm
not sure actually i don't think all they
are
you're pretty much doing all of it
nice
well i mean the idea is that it's mostly
just keen
and you just fill in the gaps because
the grass as a grass field works as a
nice large green screen it's just a very
poor green screen but it works
you just gotta like push it into place i
did go a little more detail than
probably needed to did a piece for the
head piece for the body oh wow all
separate masks yeah
wow
it's been five hours
so it's been five hours since the
initial siege and what's going on
sporadically
but you know what
at this point
it's about the man next year
[Music]
hello
oh dude i'm ready
[Music]
next direct hit wins
[ __ ] i'm not even in
that's my condom sir hey you know those
things are usable now
go ahead i got more ah
you just threw it on my face
i thought i missed i thought i missed oh
my god dude
i can't see it oh don't touch it that
was a lot of fun uh we're gonna keep
these around because i'm sure they'll
come in handy for whatever else we can
put in there the first time i've ever
used a reusable nerf dart condom gun but
you know i gotta say i was impressed
[Laughter]
i'm so angry at you
[Laughter]
it's like it's like a circus out there
hey what's that channel called that
where they lip sync everybody they do
like nfl videos and donald trump and
like oh bad lip reading bad lip reading
that's right
what's up
i found a new way to organize a camera
room
what uh what'd you do
i'm about to get punked right now
what's going on
what did you do
[Music]
i knew he was in here somewhere
where maybe he's not in here
oh that's pretty good
oh wow i could like feel you know you
can feel someone's presence
as i've moved this way i like i can i
felt it and i was like what it's kind of
like where is he oh that was good
oh it's cool all right man i've been up
here for like half an hour
did you learn
your lesson
if you guys subscribe you'll be notified
of the next time you upload a video
which is probably you know tomorrow day
after tomorrow today even and also go to
bonfill.com
eco to get 25 off your first purchase of
clothes
[Music]